just a little cherry on top of the
sundae of this wonderful week
there was a race in new jersey or a
state rep race right
and the state rep race no one was really
paying attention to it because it had
the top
democrat lawmaker in new jersey a guy by
the name of steve sweeney and so he was
super powerful he was that no one was
going to really challenge him and so
there was just this guy this republican
truck driver named edward durr he spent
153 dollars on his campaign quite a lot
of it on donuts
it's not a joke
and that's always gonna be a throwaway
whatever you know we'll get him next
time
and then the truck driver won
the top democrat went down
and this guy edward durr
who spent 153 dollars on his campaign he
won
now look i don't
i don't know anything about edward durr
i i hope he's a good
candidate i love that he beat the
democrat i hope he he
is a good
politician and i hope he learns to
become a good politician and he's got i
just i really don't know nobody really
knows a lot about him right now
but i love the victory and i love the
victory because
what it shows is
people
are really sick
of this ruling class
okay and they just
they want anything but this ruling class
and it shows that we can at least
sometimes
boot this ruling class
out of power
the vote for edward dur look he might be
the greatest candidate in the world but
the fact that you've got such a
low-funded sort of unknown candidate
comes in and beats the top democrat
that's probably more of a protest vote
it's a protest vote against something
and even in new jersey even in blue new
jersey that's a great sign how did you
like that clip did you like it i hope
you liked it if you did maybe you leave
me a comment maybe you ring that bell
maybe you get those notifications more
importantly though
head on over to apple podcasts or
spotify or google play or stitcher or
your record player in your living room
or wherever you get your audio podcasts
subscribe to the michael knowles show
leave a five star review i greatly
appreciate it i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you